one of the stars of a new Disney show
has has just come out
to express hope that the show will
appeal to transgender children by
validating their views and this is a
young woman named Zoe tarakis she's
surgically had her breasts cut off by
some quack doctor she identifies as
quote non-binary and transmasculine she
says I think as trans people growing up
I didn't get to see myself anywhere so I
didn't really know that I existed
you didn't know you existed
and especially not in the hero superhero
shower movie and so I think I just feel
deeply grateful and moved that little
trans kids and trans teens have
something to look at
and to know they exist and to know that
they can have superpowers and that's
where we belong so this is obviously
I'm sure the content is going to be
terrible but this is terribly dangerous
content too
this is the sort of content that we
should not allow to Air and there are
two ways to stop this Disney's a big
platform they got a lot of audience so
we can build our own Disney
which we're doing by the way we here
specifically we are doing that here
we're the only group that's doing it to
my knowledge in the in the entire
country so I'm all for that build
Alternatives you have to build Market
alternatives
but that's not enough
it's not enough to say well politics is
Downstream of culture or just build your
own Disney build your
it's important to engage in that but
that's not enough we have got to wield
political power to fight this and I
don't care which side of the GOP you are
on
almost everybody seems to be in
agreement
on this point
the real super squishes like ASA
Hutchinson in Arkansas the squishy
Republican Governor there they're not
totally on board but almost everybody to
the right of him is okay this is a great
moment there's a ton of public support
behind this
now is the time to go especially as we
enter the 2024 primary contest every
Republican is going to be trying to
outflank each other to the right good
this can we're down to the benefit of
the party base and of the country keep
on pushing guys and wield your political
power to stop this dangerous nonsense
you know there was a story about the AP
black studies curriculum
is of course out of the College Board
it's for a new AP class
AP stands for advanced placement these
are
supposedly college level classes that
people take in high school but they're
actually just High School classes
they're just slightly more advanced and
so so the teachers flatter the students
by calling it a college course
but they're taught in high schools this
is for kids 14 years old to 18 years old
and this black studies course
taught all sorts of crazy things
about queer studies about feminist
studies about
anti-whiteness about all the rest of it
and so DeSantis says we're going to boot
this out of Florida high schools
now of course the libs call him a big
terrible racist
but one Florida Democrat County
Commissioner who happens to be a black
man is agreeing with santus
he says this is Leon County Commissioner
Bill Proctor says I think it's trash
there's grave concern about the tone and
the tenor of leadership's voice from the
highest spaces in our state being
hostile to the teaching of
African-American history frankly I'm
against the college board's curriculum I
think it's trash it's not
African-American history it is ideology
I've taught African-American history
I've structured syllabuses for
African-American history I am
African-American history and talking
about queer and feminism and all of that
for the struggle for freedom and
equality and justice
of black history has nothing to do with
queerness and feminist thought at all
totally totally agree he's obviously
right and it shows you
what the Democrats are counting on what
the libs are counting on here is that
they can call anything they want black
they can call anything they want
you know a women's issue they can they
can they can call any crazy thing they
want a civil rights issue and then they
will divide People based on race and sex
so they take this radical course based
on the
cultural developments of 20th century
Western Marxism critical theory which is
what all of these studies courses come
out of and they say okay well we're
going to teach you about weird gay stuff
and weird feminist stuff and all sorts
and anti-white people and to hate the
western civilization but as long as we
call it black studies no one's going to
be able to criticize it
and then this black County Commissioner
says um I can criticize it why the hell
are you teaching people about weird
queer stuff under the banner of black
studies doesn't make any sense
it's transparent all it requires is a
little bit of Courage from people to say
hold on you're not going to pull the
wool over my eyes don't tell me don't
tell me that pushing transgenderism is
somehow essential to teaching the black
experience in America give me a break
and so the the pushback from the state
obviously starting with the scientists
but other people like this County
Commissioner it's working the College
Board has now revised the black studies
course and and said that they'll tone it
down a little bit so they're taking out
aspects like black black queer studies
intersectionality and activism black
feminist literary thought the
reparations movement these writers
Kimberly Crenshaw the Communist
terrorist Angela Davis they're they're
now apparently removing all of these
things and adding in new student project
sections that that will replace them
that are somewhat less controversial
this again is is where I I love the
primary process
because don't kid yourself I know
DeSantis hasn't declared he's running
yet but he is practically speaking
running for president right now he's got
his campaign book coming out he is being
attacked by the only declared Republican
candidate right now he's holding press
conferences constantly he's raising a
lot of money so you have to view what's
going on in the State of Florida through
the lens of the 2024 Republican
presidential primary
and that's a good thing I like that
because it's it's DeSantis is already
moving to the right he's already doing a
great job governing in Florida this is
going to increase the pressure to go
even further to the right and what I
would say here is
stand firm
black studies has no place in high
schools
women's studies has no place in high
schools none of the critical studies
departments and pseudo-academic
disciplines have any place in high
schools
those studies disciplines are are a
thinly veiled uh
ideological
lesson plan for a a
but left-wing activism that is grounded
in the western Marxist tradition that's
all it's about
it's about the Frankfurt School it's
about the new left of the 1960s some of
the exponents of the Frankfurt School
like Herbert Mark who is a it's about a
radical uh leftist agenda that says that
that the activists are going to go into
the schools they're going to transform
the common sense they're going to
achieve cultural hegemony and they're
going to have a revolution not by
convincing the workers of the world to
unite and throw off the shackles at the
at the factory but by poisoning the
minds of westerners to hate their own
country to hate their traditions and to
to disavow the greatest achievements of
their culture kick this crap out of the
schools I don't care I'm glad they got
rid of intersectionality lessons in the
class I'm glad they got rid of the weird
queer stuff
it's not enough get rid of the studies
departments
teach history teach English teach math
teach biology teach normal subjects that
will edify students and help their
education all this radical studies kind
of nonsense get it out of there the rest
of the show continues now we've got a
story that I haven't gotten to we will
get to that and we will get to all of
your comments so become a member right
now dailywire.com
Knowles kwles use code Knowles at
checkout yet two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
foreign